foreign  [Laughter]  a little strange throwing your own baby  shower I just need it to be perfect  nothing's going to be any different it's  just a baby how how big are they even  you know  [Music]  you ready  well this says they like to suck swaddle  and swing I don't need some books  your babies are so quiet what's your  secret  there's nothing wrong with her babies  cry it's tough  oh hi hi Joe you need a rest  I care if we be myself  I feel like I'm disappearing  everyone goes through this  don't you understand she's killing me  to believe that I'm crazy  but I know what you're doing  oh there's instincts never die  [Music]  open the door  [Music]  [Applause]